c'est officiel le prochain candidat qui
représentera la france à l'eurovision
2020 a été choisi il s'agit de tome hleb
un choix fait en interne par france
télévisions si son nom vous dit
certainement quelque chose ce n'est pas
pour rien car tome hleb n'est autre que
le fils de l'humoriste michel leeb et le
jeune homme âgé de 30 ans a plus d'une
corde à son arc
en plus d'un physique très avantageux
dôme les bêtes également crooner acteur
et humoriste
on a également pu le voir dans deux
saisons de sous le soleil de
saint-tropez en 2013 et 2014 sur tf1 tu
penses que si on fume tu va chapeauter
gauche marc tu penses que tu as à mieux
dormir ailleurs ou encore dans un
épisode de la série section de
recherches sydom lab semble être un
artiste complet de nombreux internautes
estiment toutefois qu'il n'aurait pas
été choisi pour ses qualités artistiques
mais bel et bien parce qu'il est un
enfant de star une situation que
beaucoup de fils et filles connaissent
difficile de se faire un nom et de
s'imposer légitimement dans un domaine
lorsqu'on a des parents célèbres un cas
de figure auquel ont pu être confrontés
les dix roses des benjamin castaldi
le prince harry ou encore alain fabien
et anthony delon les fils de deux
monstres sacrés du cinéma
alors selon vous les enfants de stars
sont ils des privilégiés
[Musique]
les enfants de stars sont ils
privilégient je vais répondre à la
question sur tom l'ep tout de suite tu
enlèves je vous le dis igal y voilà il
fallait pas qu'ils galèrent mais il fait
son travail depuis des années il va dans
des petits théâtres
il avait fait très bien duo comique il
chante très bien si je rencontrais
avignon c'est un garçon c'était vraiment
la galère avignon non mais je vous dis
il faut vraiment aimer me lève et je me
lève il n'a pas du tout été par son aile
t&d par son père combien de fois je les
ai vus galérer dans les cafés-théâtres
j'ai eu plein de fois au téléphone et
c'est vrai que voilà c'est un garçon la
bosnie qui poste qui bossent qui bossent
et voilà et aux lions donné sa chance et
je pense que c'est une très bonne idée
de france télé alors aussi est ce que
les enfants de stars sont privilégiés
benjamin castaldi vous dites oui bah oui
évidemment parce qu'ils ont ils ont la
connexion ils ont la facilité de pouvoir
rencontrer des gens à ce moment là après
moi ce qu'ils jettent ou m'a souvent
posé la question quand j'ai commencé ce
que tu es pistonné pas dire non
évidemment j'avais la chance de
connaître mais j'ai le brickyard entre
ma mère a appelé du château quinault
valable pas à main il n'a pas de boulot
et qu'est ce que t'as pas un petit truc
pour lui c'est comme ça que ça s'est
fait à lait pour faire un stage je les
lis comme on voir un stagiaire tournée
des cafés
après il me fait faire des essais il a
clos en moi et c'est moi ça me dérange
pas tellement qui à piston ce dans tous
les métiers qui vous êtes le fils de
charcutier si vous êtes du du talent ben
ça me pose pas de problème
vincent cassel sont son père était une
star vincent il a fait des émules du
cirque il a travaillé et appris les
bourrées de talents qu'il est le
problème
cama soir il paraît donc honnêtement oui
on est privé parce qu'on a accès à une
chose que des gens du voyage n'ont pas
forcément accès mais c'est tout
maintenant mot pardon je pas d'accord
avec toi effectivement ils sont
privilégiés et oui quel est le problème
il ya un problème effectivement tu le
dis tu te retrouves et chroniqueur sur
france 2 en access avec drucker
pardon mais bcc is néanmoins faut passer
mille casting du monde c'était une
chance gigantesque est-ce que sans ça tu
serais là aujourd'hui certainement pas
malgré le talent est là où je dis
qu'effectivement wii est privilégiée ces
mêmes avantages on sait très bien que
plus compliquée dans la vie c'est pas
forcément de réussir c'est d'atteindre
l'endroit où on veut aller une fois qu
on y est et qu'on est bien placé et bien
souvent on arrive à faire son trou qu'on
est un peu de talent ou pas forcément
sur dix est le plus compliqué c'est
l'endroit où vous voulez à l'enfant la
collection
oui oui et mettre effectivement qu'il
est beau qu'il arrive 8e 10e 12e au 15e
peu importe
effectivement oui les privilégiés et oui
c'est un énorme avantage disons le alors
j'ai merdé bien sûr c'est le drame de la
société française c'est une société de
pistonner c'est à dire que si vous
n'êtes pas si vous n'avez pas la carte
si vous n'avez pas la filière si vous
n'avez pas l'opportunité vous ne pouvez
pas exprimer votre talent tous ses fils
on dit parfois encore faut-il qu'ils se
fassent un prénom mais il y en a pour
qui il faut se faire un nom et un prénom
c'est beaucoup plus dur s'il vous plaît
je voudrais être le fils d'une superstar
six epr est un excellent booster de
carrière à l'image de celle de david et
idées même si dans l'intimité il avait
avoué voilà que tout n'était pas rose
avec son papa regarde tu as un bon père
ah ouais ouais ouais c'est un très bon
père très bon père aurait bien aimé
avoir
on va dire plus de deux rapports mais
bon la distance compliqué hein
il vous a dit qu'il vous aider oui tu es
très pudique
d'ailleurs moi aussi je très pudique
elle on est un petit peu c'est ce qui
nous caractérise dans la famille quand
on dit je t'aime c'est qu'il ya vraiment
un élan du coeur aux chinois c'est vrai
mais on peut le penser mais oui quand on
était tous les deux oui oui alors ça n'a
rien à voir des célébrités on peut
avouer ne pas avoir deux frères alors un
père absent qui nie pas je t'aime et
privilégier non isabelle mans alors moi
j'ai ouïe évidemment que ce que je vous
dis tous les deux que ce qu'ils disent
tous les deux et bon vivant séparé il ya
une énorme contre vérité c'est que ça
fait gagner effectivement du temps les
connexions bien sûr mais personne ne
peut jamais obligé le public à regarder
quelqu'un qu'il ne peut pas voir ou pas
ses lèvres ça c'est une vraie vraie un
match habib ben je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est
le public c'est le dernier censeurs
c'est le public qui décide
et effectivement ils sont privilégiés
parce qu'ils vont au cours de théâtre
plus rapidement ils ont les connexions
mais on ne situe n'a pas le talent tu ne
peux pas y arriver les produits à leur
naissance et qu'elle ne fait pas ce
métier quand tu le fais 80 % tête j'ai
un peu le talent et les décès des
personnes à 4 ans ils sont déjà là au
théâtre sont déjà avec la costumière et
tous y sont baignées de danse à total
mythique c'est le public qui décide mais
quand t'es pas connue table même pas le
public tu veux tu as même pas la chance
de voir un président devant le public
sur qui on peut te remarquer nantes et
enfin d'un grand réalisateur kim a dîné
chez départ en quittant match on
apprenait en font mal à comprendre le
chien honecker qui a accédé à la
télévision sur n'importe quelle chaîne
qui était inconnu arrivée de ces
messieurs cette émission par cette
émission il a dit oui c'est vrai qu'on
est privilégié quand on est ravissante
mais oui à les réprimer elle est à côté
il ya des alliances aussi sinon sons et
des paroles c'est pas le cas de tous qui
guillaume depardieu en parler sur le
plateau tradition regardez bien le fils
de gérard je le déteste les mêmes
raisons son impuissance
non mais c'est toujours pareil de façon
les gens les aiment quand on les aime
vraiment si on les aime aussi pour leurs
défauts il n'a pas été assez dur avec
vous pensez franchement non je n'en mets
c'est une manière autrement plus dur
aussi de
dire à quelqu un des meilleurs toi tu
vas voir à la dure quoi mais moi je
trouve que ça m'a amené vers une liberté
qui est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
doigt le concéder je trouve que c'est
intéressant de dire à quelqu'un démerde
toi toute façon tu vas être bien être
obligé de te démerder donc mais c'était
peut-être un peu tôt
alors nous sommes affectés en mai il ya
un problème c'est que les français en
fait des tests les privilèges les
français veulent que tout le monde soit
sur le même pied d'égalité tout le monde
galère de la même manière les gens sont
assez envieux de la chance et de la
réussite des autres
donc effectivement les enfants de stars
sont privilégiés il ya aussi une grosse
pression derrière pour ce qui concerne
la réussite et le pied à l'étrier
certes mais à l'époque on se rappelle
par exemple vanessa paradis quand elle a
commencé
c'est grâce à son oncle didier par
accepter aujourd'hui à des machos de
partout que ce soit pour la cuisine que
ce soir un trou pour le théâtre que ce
soit par exemple pour la chanson dans
tous les messieurs on a dans tous les
métiers si on a du talent on peut
réussir même si on n'a pas entendu la
tuna mais déjà la news de gilles donc
c'est vrai que cyril son papa faisait la
télévision est arrivé à gras savoye
lassons pas parler mon père ce qui est
dommage c'est mon papa sa maman faisait
pas de la télé à la résonance et kaka
turcot en effet et benjamin l'a très
bien dit que quand on a été baigné
depuis tout petit dans un univers
cinématographique sportive citypass
parlant de ses deux parents son prof de
tennis monsieur robert lui-même est
devenu champion parce que les les fils
de profs ils travaillent très bien à
l'école libre parce qu'ils ont des
parents qui sont eux qui peuvent les
aider
donc forcément mais je trouve que vous
êtes totalement dans la caricature
totalement dans la démagogie et que de
toute façon le piston ne sert pas si on
doit pas durer il faut durer dans la
ville insulaire fille
manifestants saluent quoi c'est d'accord
avec g
et puis ça pête douloureux en fait c'est
oui je les assume l'un des parents
briché du bureau de pékin sur dallas
fait pas peur mais regardez musardé en
tout cas qu'à toi bien
[Musique]